this is the nakivali refugee settlement
in western uganda
130 000 people live here
six years ago dina nabintu fled the
democratic republic of congo
after rebels killed her husband
the lake is the source of water also for
drinking
for livestock as well
but the water is full of germs
every year 20 000 children under the age
of five die in uganda of diarrheal
disease
one major reason is that they have no
choice but to drink dirty water
heat kills germs so dina nabintu boils
the water she fetches from the lake
she has five children
drinking water using charcoal and if we
don't have it we use firewood
otherwise we will be drinking very dirty
water
that comes at a cost to the environment
to make charcoal
trees are cut down forest also had to be
cleared to make space for the settlement
but there's another way to provide safe
clean drinking water
sauda birungi and henrio fienno run
tusofisha
a social enterprise that makes automated
low-cost filters
this setup cost twelve hundred dollars
the money was donated by somebody in the
united states
it supplies enough water for about 900
people out of 130 000 in the settlement
but it's still a start the water that
passes through
our filter is the water from the lake
you can see this is
the original water from the lake and
then after it passes through the filter
this is the result that we get
sauda birungi lost a brother to cholera
he drank contaminated water access to
clean water is a human right
tusafisha aims to deliver what the state
fails to provide
it also developed a small water filter
for home use
it uses granite to
to purify the water we have two buckets
the top bucket contains the granite and
then the lower bucket is a reservoir for
the
safe water so they pour water on the top
bucket
and then the whole filtration happens in
the granite
only water and air can escape through
the granite and only safe water goes
into the reservoir for safe water down
othyano shows people how to put together
their own water filter
the granite needs to be cleaned every
few months then it can be reused
dinan is intrigued if you filter water
this way you no longer have to boil it
or buy charcoal which means lower
emissions and costs
and there's another advantage every time
we install an institution filter
we train the women around the community
to make sure that they have access to
safe drinking water
in their homes they can also go and
train
other people or also make these water
filters
then sell them to an extra income for
themselves
sauda birunji and henrio thieno
installed the first
large filtering system using granite in
central uganda
in a school near the capital kampala
several hundred pupils now have access
to clean water
and fall sick less often
this water is safe doesn't have anything
so
it has helped me a lot because i'm no
longer suffering with thai food one day
when i was suffering with typhoid and i
was like
i don't even go to school tusa fisher
has installed the institutional scale
filter systems in more than 30 schools
so far
here at saint bruno's in in piggy
district near kampala
the system is the school's pride and joy
it cost 600
the parents each contributed about a
dollar
the school still uses wood but only for
cooking not for boiling water to make it
safe
this is good for health the environment
and the budget
we used to buy followers
or firewood but right now
we've tried to save a little bit and
from four lollies now we can buy
three lollies a term tucson fisher has
quantified the impact that use of its
filters has on the environment
in terms of trees protected and co2
emissions
for every filter that we install in a
school
every day we save 1500
kilograms of carbon dioxide emitted in
the atmosphere
in a year we save the atmosphere of
at least 240 tons of carbon dioxide
for each filter and moringa trees that
we plant
whenever tucson fisher installs a large
filter system in a school
the team plants moringa trees with the
pupils about a thousand in all
over the past two years
moringa's absorbed carbon dioxide at an
amazingly high rate
20 times the rate of general vegetation
according to one japanese study
[Music]
but tusofisha aims to do more than just
replace trees that have been selled
we need to begin writing these ideas of
protecting the environment into the
minds of the people while they are still
young
the tradition in uganda and many african
countries
is that you cut trees to purify water we
want to
change that tradition totally at naki
vale
dina nabintu has since acquired and
started using a water filter
she put it together herself
[Music]
filter she and her family stand a better
chance of staying healthy with less
effort
and at lower cost however dirty the
water in the lake
continues to be
you